c'est moi hier en ukraine une guerre qui
risque donc de durer on en parle avec
karim hakiki qui m'a rejoint sur ce
plateau karim bonjour des russes on se
dirige vers une guerre de position est
loin loin de la gare est clair annoncé
par les russes en début du conflit et
bien l'offrons hausse en lice on va
essayer de comprendre où en sont les
combats avec deux cartes d'abord une
première carte qui nous montre
qu'aujourd'hui ce sont dans le sud où
les principaux affrontements au lieu
nous avons le dombass ici est la crimée
ce territoire qui est déjà été conquis
et occupé à part les russes et bien les
affrontements se s'étendre sur 350 et
kilomètres le long de cette frontière
sud depuis les environs de zappos ridja
jusqu'à acquarone que font les russes eh
bien ils encerclent il essaye de revenir
vers cette seconde basse et 7 crimée où
on sait ainsi ce sont des régions
majoritairement russophone et bien les
russes concentrent leurs efforts là
parce que depuis le début de l'opération
ils n'ont pas été capables de d'avoir
une offensive d'abord autour de kiev ça
a été ça commençait là et puis de
maintenir leurs positions autour de ces
deux enclaves russophone autour de
l'ukraine alors les ukrainiens comment
ils se défendent face à cette offensive
au contre offensive russe eh bien ils
adoptent une stratégie défensive qui va
bloquer l'avancée inde et des chars et
des blindés russes notamment dans la
région de kara scott
les tensions là se fige autour de la
centrale de sa peau rica qui crée
beaucoup d'inquiétude
ici en ukraine et dans la communauté
internationale et bien les deux les deux
belligérants moscou et et kiev
s'accusent mutuellement de bombarder les
environs de la centrale on sait pas
exactement en tout cas il y aurait une
enquête de l'agencé internationale de
l'énergie atomique qui pourraient se
déplacer sur place mais pour le moment
nous n'avons pas les contours de cette
de cette enquête donc comme on le voit
sur la carte le conflit s'est enlisé
mais il n'a pas baissé d'intensité ça
veut dire que les russes bombarde
continuellement continuellement les
positions ukrainienne côté diplomatique
des avancées côté diplomatique très peu
d'avancé nous avons vu aujourd'hui
vladimir
volodymyr winski déclaré qu' il voulait
revenir reconquérir tout le territoire
ukrainien y compris les deux régions
dont on a parlé le don base et la crimée
qui depuis 2014 la crimée et sous le
giron russe comme on peut le voir là et
bien vous voyez toute cette région de
tous ces régions là qui sont pour
l'instant contrôlé par parler à les
russes et qui sont concernées par les
russes et bien vladimir medinski a
souhaité les récupérer emmanuel macron
s'est exprimé également aujourd'hui la
communauté internationale pour dire qu'
il n'était pas très optimistes et que
les efforts diplomatiques pour l'instant
n'ont rien donné nous assistons du côté
russe un espèce de chantage diplomatique
internationale nous voulons cette
conférence de l'iowa ou en tout cas les
les enquêteurs de la u a sur place mais
pour le moment ils n'ont donné aucune
précision sur les modalités de ces
visites en tout cas de ces contrôles
autour de cette région de sébastopol et
en crimée est également autour de la
centrale zaporizhya qui qui créé de
vives inquiétudes merci à karim